wir testen heute eine belgische friterie
und das soll eine der besten überhaupt
sein guckt euch an was ich hier
wunderschönes habe Fritten Spezial
kipkorn castrofling und Frikandel
Spezial ganz wichtig es wird nicht an
Soßen gespart und ich nehme mir direkt
mal so eine Belgische Pommes bisschen
Zwiebeln bisschen Mayo mhmm boah das ist
ja brutal das können mit die krassesten
Pommes eigentlich hier gegessen habe
perfekt knusprig flauschig und weich
innen drin
welchen Belgien leben würde dann wäre
ich glaube ich ein paar Kilo schwerer
Castle Alter ist das brutal Soße das ist
wirklich alles bisher 10 von 10 und zu
guter Letzt bekannte Spezial
vorbei wenn ihr im Backend seid kommt
ihr vorbei